العائله المالكه البريطانيه بتمر بازمه
يمكن تكون الاكبر في تاريخها والسبب
الامير هاري ومذكراته فمن بعد وثائقي
نتفليكس اللي فجرت موجه فضائح جديده
مذكرات هاي همم
المفروض تطرح فيه 10 يناير وتسربت بطريقه
ما حدش عارف ليش ولكن طرحت للبيع بنسخه
الاسبانيه وبدا نشر البلاوي اللي فيها
سلسله من الاتهامات والفضائح والذيعات من
قبل هاري ضد اسرته والعائله الملكه خلونا
او خلوني استعرض لكم مشاهدينا سريعا ابرز
ما جاء في المذاكره
هو قال انه اخوه الامير وليام في خناقه
مره ضربوا وطرحه ارضا خلال خناقه بينهم
سببها ما بين في 2019 وقال انه هو واخوه
توسل وابوهم الاميره تشارلز ما يتجوز
كامله وقال كمان انه ابوه كان بيغار من
زوجته ماجن وكاثرن زوجه ويليام وان هم
بيسرقوا منه الاضواء وانه هو مش مستعد
يتكرر يكرر هذا الشيء او يتكرر هذا الشيء
معه في اشاره لشعبيه والدته الراحله ديانا
واللي صار معها من قبل طبعا الاهتمام
الصحفي فيها وقال كمان انه سبق وتعاطي
المخدرات والحشيش في مراهقته وفي شبابه
وكشف انه قتل 25 عنصر من طالبان خلال عمله
في سلاح الجو وخدمه في افغانستان هو وصفها
بانها اشبه بازاحه قطعه شطرنج من على
اللوح هذا غير طبعا تفاصيل دقيقه عن
فقدانه العذريتهم اكبر سنا في حقل لما كان
عمره 17 سنه ايه بس
تفاصيل كمان عن حضوره ولا تصوير مشاهد
حميميه لما كان في مسلسل سوق
مذكرات الامير هاري هاي بنحكي عنها او
بنحكى عنها منشور وشهور وكان في كلام عن
مطالبات وضغوط من قبل العائله المالكه
لوقف نشرها كمان كان في تقارير تتكلم انه
نفسه فكر في وقت نشرها بعد وفاه جدته
الملكه من حوالي اربعه اشهر عموما امام كل
هذه الفضائح القصر للان ملتزم الصمت وما
اصدر اي تعليق رسمي لكن الامير هاري مش
شكله ناوي يهدي اللعب ففي مش مقابله واحده
بالبيئه اكثر من مقابله تحديدا ثلاث
مقابلات منتظره له نزلت الاعلانات
الترويجيه لها ومنتظرها هاليومين في اطار
الترويج الكتاب
المتوقع مع عرض كل هذه المقابله